(rumbling)
(bleeping)
(lively piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are, and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(ambient music)
(uptempo music)
- I'm gonna present some
data from a study I did
to evaluate the ecology
of hominin scavenging,
but I'll start by talking
a bit more broadly
about how archaeologists can use evidence
from butchered animal bones
to understand prehistoric meat-eating
in terms of potentially
both hunting and scavenging.
So, as someone who studies prehistory,
I start with a totally blank canvas
when I attempt to reconstruct
the diets of ancient humans.
I try to paint a picture of the past
that I know will always be incomplete.
We will never have all the pixels,
but I'm dedicated to finding the filters
on the lenses through which
we can peer back in time
and try to reconstruct
something rich in detail
like this National Geographic illustration
of what I can only describe
as a hominin meat picnic.
(audience laughing)
One of the fun things about
studying hominin meat-eating
is there are so many
different lines of evidence
that we can use to do so.
We can use chimpanzee
and human forager diets
and the talks earlier today
have addressed some of these.
We can look at hominin fossils themselves,
we can look at the size
and shape of teeth.
The talk before mine by
Margaret addressed this a bit.
We can look at jaws and skulls
and we can look at even
body size and shape.
We can also look at the chemistry
which is what the talk
before mine really focused on
of those actual hominin fossils.
We can look at animal
fossils, particularly those
with direct evidence for butchery
and that's what I'll focus
on a little bit after this.
To do that we often use
a method called actualism
where we either do experiments
or make observations in the present.
We look at bones on the present
for traces left of behavior
from those experiments or observations.
We then look at fossils in the past,
see if we can find similar traces
and then we can infer that
similar behaviors occurred
in the past.
We can also look at the
archeological record
at tools made by hominins
that were used for meat-eating
and we can even use newer methods
like looking at ancient molecules.
And so less than a year half ago,
a team of archeologists announced
that they had found
ancient animal proteins,
basically the residue of blood,
skin and flesh from animals
on the edges of 17 stone tools
from an excavation in Jordan
dating back to 250,000 years ago.
It kind of blows my mind a bit
that now we have direct evidence
for even what kinds of animals
hominins were butchering
a quarter of a million years ago.
In this case we're talking about camels,
wild cattle, rhino, horses and duck.
So I use a method called taphonomy,
this is the lens that I
most often look through
to examine the diets of early humans.
Taphonomy is the study of
what happens to an organism
after its death until its
discovery as a fossil.
Here's a great illustration by a paper
by Nina Jablonski and colleagues
of a possible taphonomic
scenario resulting
in the accumulation of giant
panda bones in a cave in China.
I'm particularly interested
in what happens right at
and after death.
So that's that middle row really
between boxes number three and four.
And when it comes to thinking
about hominin meat-eating
the main way to investigate
this is through the study
of animal fossils with butchery marks,
including cut marks made from skinning,
disarticulating and defleshing animals,
as well as percussion marks
left by bashing bones open
to get at the fat and calorie-rich marrow.
I also study tooth marks
and other chewing damage
left by carnivores.
The lens I use is literally a hand lens,
like a simple magnifying
glass that I can use
to identify these marks on fossil bones.
So I'm gonna take you
on a taphonomic timeline
of what we know about
the earliest evidence
for hominin carnivory.
And the bulk of the evidence
for the earliest carnivory
in human evolutionary history really comes
from three sites in Ethiopia.
The oldest is a 3.3 million
year old site called Dikika,
where a team led by people
including Jessica Thompson
and Shannon McPherron
discovered just a handful
of bones, including those
pictured on the left
with possible butchery marks on them.
Two other sites from Ethiopia
called Gona and Bouri,
the bones on the right
are from pictures of bones
with butchery marks from Bouri.
Those date to 2.6 and 2.5
million years ago respectively.
They also preserve a handful
of butchery mark fossils.
While much ink has been spilled
about whether some of these marks
are actually butchery marks
and not marks made by
crocodiles, mammalian carnivores
or other butchery mark mimics
like sedimentary abrasion,
the importance of these sites
is that they signal the beginning
of a dietary shift in hominin
evolution to occasionally,
but apparently only occasionally,
butchering and eating animals.
There was a shift at two million years ago
when we have the first evidence
of both persistent carnivory
and early access to small animals,
and I'll explain what that means.
And the image up here is of
some butchered animal fossils
from this site called Kanjera
South in Southwestern Kenya.
This is some research
that I've been involved in
led by Rick Potts and Tom Plummer
as well as Jennifer
Parkinson and Joe Ferraro.
At Kanjera there's clear evidence
from hundreds of butchery mark
fossil bones, animal bones,
that hominins acquired and
processed numerous relatively
complete small animal
carcasses for meat and marrow.
They got to these animals
first before other predators
and butchered the meatier parts of them,
so that's the early access part.
The Kanjera hominins also had
at least occasional access
to meat and marrow from
larger-sized animals.
An important difference between
this and the earlier sites
where we do see evidence
of hominin butchery
is that there's evidence
for hominin butchery
on bones at Kanjera from
three stratigraphic intervals
that span hundreds to thousands of years.
So hominins were coming back to this place
in Southwestern Kenya over and over again
over a long period of
time to butcher animals.
This is what persistent carnivory is.
And this gives us a sense
that this dietary behavior
is becoming more important
or at least it's becoming
more commonplace.
Just a little bit later in time,
a work led by David Braun
in a place called Koobi Fora
in Northern Kenya, there's evidence
for hominin butchery marks on
turtles, crocodiles and fish.
So at this time hominins
are already broadening
their butchery behavior
to include both aquatic
as well as terrestrial animals.
There is another shift that happened
about one and a half million years ago.
From several different bone assemblages
from the sites of Olduvai Gorge,
some of which date back to
about 1.8 million years ago,
and Koobi Fora, some of which date back
to 1.5 million years ago, led by a variety
of different teams, there's
evidence from the skeletal parts
that were transported and
butchered at these sites
hominins had early access
to large animal carcasses.
Basically they were now able
to get to these carcasses first
and butcher the meatier
parts of large animals.
The photo up here is a butchery marks
on one and a half million year
old fossil antelope leg bone
from Koobi Fora in Northern Kenya
and this is part of an
assemblage that I studied
and excavated as part of my dissertation.
So, you're probably picturing
hominins striding out
onto the African savanna armed
with their stone-tipped spears
getting ready to hunt these animals.
Like this bronze sculpture
reconstruction of a Homo Erectus
from the Hall of Human
Origins at the Smithsonian
carrying a goat-sized gazelle on her back.
Well, the earliest solid
evidence for hunting technology
doesn't come into the record
until half a million years ago
with the spear points from
a site called Kathu Pan
in South Africa that have
what are called diagnostic
impact fractures on their tips,
indicating that they were definitely used
as the ends of weapons.
It's possible that hominins were hunting
with unmodified rocks or
sharpened sticks made into spears
maybe like the Fongoli chimpanzees
or other basically
archeologically invisible tools,
but we haven't figured out
a way to detect this yet
in the prehistoric record.
And this is particularly likely
in the case of the small
animals at Kanjera,
so many of the small animals
themselves were juveniles,
and very young defenseless
antelopes are often stashed
in thick grass clumps for
several weeks by their mothers.
And doesn't take very
sophisticated technology
to basically walk up to
those little antelopes
and bop them on the head
and then you have dinner.
So what made early human carnivory
or early hominin carnivory unique,
particularly compared to the possible diet
of our earliest ancestors,
as well as the diets of chimpanzees?
There are four things.
The first is that it involved big animals.
And so, animals much
larger than themselves.
As you heard from the talks earlier today,
chimpanzees don't hunt animals
that are larger than themselves.
This is a really useful reconstruction
of an extinct elephant being butchered
by a group of Homo Erectus based
on a one-million-year
old archeological site
I'm involved in studying from
a Smithsonian research site
in Southern Kenya called Olorgesailie.
The second thing is that
it involved tool use,
and rare occasions including
the Fongoli chimps aside,
we don't think that our earliest ancestors
necessarily used tools when they hunted.
Hominins also don't have the sharp teeth
of mammalian carnivores to be able
to get through the skin of large animals,
let alone slice meat off of their bones
and bash them open to get marrow.
It also likely involves something
called deferred consumption,
which is basically not
eating something right away
as soon as you find it.
This is a weird thing that humans do.
We don't go to the grocery store,
sit down in the middle of the aisles,
open the packages and start eating,
I guess, unless we're really hungry.
But in the earliest record
of hominin meat-eating,
we have evidence that hominins
transported carcass parts
to central places for some
kind of communal consumption,
potentially food sharing.
So if early humans were
eating meat from large animals
for about two million years
before we have evidence,
good solid evidence
for hunting technology,
how were they getting access to them?
One suggestion is that they
were scavenging the leftovers
from large carnivore kills,
and I should point out
that this is something
that is very rarely seen
in chimpanzee behavior.
Chimps don't seem to look at dead things
and think of them as food,
things that are already dead.
So what does scavenging look like
behaviorally and ecologically?
There have been two
main kinds of scavenging
that have been proposed
for early hominins.
The first is called confrontational
or aggressive or power scavenging.
This is when hominins
actively chase carnivores off
of kills, presumably getting access
to a lot of meat and
marrow in the process.
There was probably a
pretty high risk of injury
or predation of the hominins
themselves when they did this.
And there are a few
hominins with bite marks
on them from carnivores to
indicate that this did happen
at least occasionally.
The second is passive scavenging,
and this is waiting until carnivores
are completely done eating a kill,
they've moved off, the scene is safe,
hominins could go in
and eat the leftovers.
One of the main criticisms of
the passive scavenging idea
is that there probably wouldn't
be much worth going after
when carnivores were
done eating their fill.
But is this the case?
I decided to try to answer this question
by simulating passive scavenging
in a modern African
ecosystem similar to those
in which our earliest
meat-eating ancestors lived.
And I'm very happy to leave simulating
confrontational scavenging
to somebody else.
(clears throat)
(audience laughing)
So is passive scavenging worth it?
The research I'll be
talking about here was part
of my dissertation and it
was published a few years ago
in the Journal of Human Evolution.
In 2002 to 2003, I spent
seven months in a game reserve
in central Kenya called
Ol Pejeta Conservancy,
which you can see here on
a zoomed in map of Kenya,
and I simulated passive scavenging.
I specifically chose this
conservancy, Ol Pejeta,
because the felid, the carnivore community
is dominated by lions, and most
models of hominin scavenging
are based on interactions
with large felids,
including lions, leopards
and extinct saber tooths.
There have been a few
other scavenging studies
that were done before
mine but these were done
in the Serengeti and Ngorongoro
ecosystems of Tanzania,
as well as the Maasai
Mara ecosystem of Kenya
that's actually all one big ecosystem
that happens to be separated
by an international border.
But these ecosystems have
unusually high numbers
of predators and
particularly high competition
among predator species.
So I was interested in going
to a felid-dominated ecosystem
to simulate passive scavenging.
Ol Pejeta is an African savanna ecosystem,
it was about 100 square
kilometers when I was there.
It was called Sweetwaters
Game Reserve when I was there.
Now it's been expanded to
almost four times that size.
And here you see some images
of what it looked like there.
It has mixed grassland
and woodland vegetation.
All the photos on this slide are photos
I took in the reserve.
The vegetation map on the top left
shows open grassy areas that are in black.
They generally run east to
west on kind of high plateaus.
The photos with the
giraffe with the zebras
in the background are a good example
of what those open grassy areas look like.
There's a permanent river
called the Ewaso Ng'iro
that runs north south through the reserve.
You can see that on the western
side with that green strip.
That green is basically
riverine vegetation,
trees particularly dominated
by yellow fever acacia
or acacia that's xanthophloea.
There's a picture of
that on the top right.
The dominant bush in the
ecosystem is called euclea.
This is noted in the bright blue areas,
you can see that on the top middle.
Whistling thorn acacia
or acacia drepanolobium
are also very prevalent,
those are noted in light
blue on the vegetation map.
And the yellow and pink
areas on that map are areas
of mixed bushland, woodland and grassland
in kind of different proportions.
The predator community during the time
of my study was dominated by
lions as I mentioned already
and the herbivore community
was dominated by zebras
followed by warthog,
impala, buffalo and baboon.
So, my study methods were pretty simple.
After finding out about a carnivore kill
from a variety of sources, I would wait
until the lions were completely satiated,
like this one in this photo
(audience laughing)
with a distended belly full of warthog,
this was a really happy sleepy lion,
and I would document what
was left on their kills.
I had two advantages over
my earlier ancestors.
I had a four-wheel drive vehicle
and I had an armed guard
with me at all times
lessening the likelihood
of me becoming one
of my own samples.
(audience laughing)
In the time that I was at Ol Pejeta,
I collected 24 kill samples
from several different species
of carnivores which you
can see in the left column
of this table, but I'm
gonna focus particularly
on the lion kills today as
that's my largest sample
and the most relevant for thinking
about models of hominins scavenging.
I separated the prey into
two size divisions related
to how we classify the size of animals
when we're doing archeological analysis,
but here I'm just generally
calling them large or small.
Larger animals are over 250 pounds,
small animals less than 250 pounds.
I documented the location
and estimated the amount
of meat left over after
the lions had their fill
and here are some examples
of what these leftovers looked like.
The top right is a
picture of a zebra ribcage
with quite a bit of meat left on it
and the bottom right is a
picture of a part of a limb
of a young Grant's gazelle
with hardly any scraps left.
And I should say specifically
that I followed previous
researchers in defining bulk flesh
as masses of muscle at least
10% of their original size,
flesh scraps were usually
pieces of flesh less than size
of the palm of your hand, but
over two to three centimeters
and weighing more than
about a third of a pound.
So how much meat can a scavenger
eat from a large animal,
something like a zebra
or a large antelope?
I'm gonna walk you through
the axis of this graph
before I show you the data.
So the x-axis is a skeletal
element or bone arranged
in groups from left to right
with the total sample size
of each bone listed in parentheses.
The important part is the left two bones,
they're bones of the hindlimb,
then bones of the forelimb,
then bones of the torso, and all the way
on the right are bones
of the head and neck.
The y-axis is the
proportion of those bones
in all samples with three different levels
of flesh availability,
and I basically colored
them like a traffic light.
Green for bulk flesh,
yellow for flesh scraps
and red for no flesh.
So what did I find?
You see a lot of green
and yellow on there.
In large kills, over 50%
of bones were abandoned
with large muscle masses
still on them in green,
and 95% of the bones had either bulk flesh
or flesh scraps which you see in yellow.
That's from large prey.
Small prey is a different story.
Only a single bone on smaller lion kills
retained bulk flesh on it.
About half the bone still
had some flesh scraps
and the other half were totally defleshed,
you can see that in red.
And one take-home from the study
is that if you're an
early human scavenging
from a lion kill, the size
of the prey really matters.
So, how does this translate into actually
how much meat a scavenger could eat?
We can use weights of
adult wildebeest and zebra
which are pictured here.
The hindlimb of wildebeest
yields about 19 pounds of meat,
a zebra about 50 pounds.
A defleshed hindlimb of
a wildebeest would be
about two pounds, defleshed
zebra about five pounds.
That's only a single hindlimb.
A defleshed wildebeest carcass
could yield 12 pounds of meat.
A defleshed a zebra carcass could yield
about 34 pounds of meat.
So if we estimate a four
calories per gram of meat,
this is about 2,200
calories from a wildebeest
and almost 6,100 calories from a zebra,
and these are defleshed.
So, translating this into
things we can understand here,
that's about a little more than five
and a half In-N-Out burgers
worth of meat from a wildebeest,
a little more than 15 and
a half in burgers worth
of meat from a zebra.
I'm using an estimate of
somewhere between 2,100
and 2,300 calories per day
required for Homo Erectus.
A defleshed wildebeest is pretty much
your daily caloric requirement.
This is even without breaking the bones
to get at the marrow inside.
So the main take-home message
is that I think scavenging
from even relatively defleshed carcasses
would have been a profitable
and worthwhile activity for hominins.
I just want to acknowledge
Government of Kenya,
the funding, my PhD advisor and
the people and the predators
and the prey of Ol Pejeta.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- So the idea that women have
evolved to be plant gatherers
and men hunters has dominated
evolutionary thinking
in the popular imagination for decades.
It's been suggested that
men are better navigators
than women as a result of a long history
of natural selection on hunters
who can pursue mobile prey
across vast landscapes
without getting lost.
Men are thought to be more
cooperative than women
because throughout our
evolutionary history
they've needed to work together
to bring down hunted prey
much larger than themselves.
Men's hunting is argued to
have driven the evolution
of our two-legged gait, supplied
the nutritional advantages
and protein and fat to support
our energetically-expensive brain
and given our juveniles the luxury
of a long pre-reproductive
life of relative leisure
in which they can take the time to learn
all the skills of adulthood.
Although it's widely recognized
that women's gathering
is usually the more reliable contributor
to family subsistence,
we also tend to think
that men's hunting must be
on the whole more productive
than women's foraging
because they often take
very large animals.
Some have even argued that the
origins of the nuclear family
where men and women cooperate
in different tasks lie
in the evolutionary origins
of female specializing
in childcare and depending
on a man's hunting production
in order to feed her children.
The generalization that men tend to hunt
and women gather holds
for some well-known
contemporary hunter-gatherers.
So among the Hadza in
Tanzania for example,
women primarily gather plant foods,
lower-quality small-packaged food items
high in carbohydrates.
And men typically spend
their time hunting,
acquiring higher-quality
large-packaged food items high
in protein and fat.
Similarly, among the Juǀʼhoansi
in Botswana and Namibia
and the Ache in Paraguay, women
specialize almost entirely
on plant-based foods while men hunt.
However, this is not a universal pattern.
There is a great deal of variation
among hunter-gatherers in the extent
to which women do
specialize on plant foods.
And many hunter-gatherer
women do acquire animals.
There's the Ata, the Ainu, and the Dene,
where women hunt deer.
The Cree where women
hunt caribou and geese.
Central African Aka women hunt
for duikers and forest pigs.
Mixed-gender communal hunts
for rabbits were common
among the Shoshone,
and Paiute women hunted
and in many cases still
hunt ground squirrels
and prairie dogs.
Australia is another place that
challenges our understanding
of who hunts and why.
Across Australia, pre-historically women
were active hunters.
They had a primary focus
on the hand capture
of small to medium-sized animals.
And in many locations,
women skillfully used fire
and hunted with dogs to
improve their efficiency.
For example, Phyllis Kayberry
found Walmajarri women
in the Kimberly in 1935 were using dogs
to hunt kangaroo and monitor lizards.
And she suggested that
the family was dependent
on the woman's efforts to a greater extent
than on those of her husband.
In the 1950s, Jane Goodall also found
that Tiwi women were active
and productive hunters.
And she too characterized women
as the most consistent providers
not only of plant foods,
but of meat as well,
especially meat from small animals.
People I work with, Martu.
Martu women of Australia's
Western Desert, too,
are hunters more than anything else.
On any given day between about 60 to 70%
of the bush food that's produced
is from women's hunting.
Women take more than half of the perentie.
This is one of the largest
species of monitor lizard,
aside from the Komodo dragon.
Women also take a little more
than half of the feral cats.
Feral cats spread into the desert starting
about 100 years ago and
were readily adopted
as prey by Martu hunters.
Women will take about 20% of the bustards
and 6% of the kangaroos.
So bustards are the largest
flying bird in Australia
and males can weigh up to 20 kilograms.
Kangaroo are the largest
endemic non-human in Australia
and weigh up to 80 kilograms.
So these are large for Australia,
not for Africa, but for Australia.
The staple prey of Martu women
are the smaller sand monitor lizards,
sometimes called goanna.
And they acquire more than 80% of them.
They're easily the most
abundant large vertebrate
in the desert.
They weigh about half a kilo.
Women hunt them in two
ways which vary seasonally.
In the hot summer months
they track the monitors
on the surface hoping to chase them
to trees or corner them in the open
to avoid having to dig
them out of their dens.
In the winter the monitors
are denned most of the time
and they have to be dug out.
So to accomplish this and also to aid
in the search for fresh dens,
women burn the spinifex grass
that obscures the tracks and signs.
Women often cooperate with each other
in sand monitor and perentie hunting.
So they work together to
burn an area for hunting
to locate tracks and dens and
then to extract the animal.
Now, the most important
thing nutritionally
about a monitor lizard is
not the meat, it's the fat.
So lizards become dormant
in the cool season.
They lay down about 10 to
20% of their body weight
in the form of large fat
bodies in the abdomen and tail.
And most people say a skinny lizard
isn't actually worth eating.
So women really pride themselves
on being able to find
and capture fat ones.
Now while Martu women do a lot of hunting,
they also do most of the collecting too.
So they produce nearly
100% of things like roots,
98% of insect larva, 90% of the fruit,
a lot of the nectar and
about 30% of the honey.
Now, in comparison, men are
looking for small things.
About 30% of the time
they're out foraging,
but most of the time they prefer to search
for the larger animals like
emu, kangaroo and bustard.
And rather than hunting
cooperatively like women,
they primarily hunt alone.
Now, the social context of hunting
is similar to what you might see
in any hunter-gatherer society.
So women leave the residential camp
in a group of other women,
often with children along.
They establish what
they call a dinner camp.
They acquire food.
They return to that
temporary dinner camp to cook
and consume food socially,
and then they return
to the residential camp
at the end of the day.
So the question that I'm
gonna to start off with
is why are women hunting?
So, traditionally, if we
think about men's hunting,
the goals of men's hunting
are explained usually
in one of two ways.
So either men are hunting in order
to provision a nuclear family
or men are hunting to show off their skill
and attract alliances and
favorable attention from women.
In many cases, the kinds
of hunting that men do
don't appear to be well-designed
to provision others.
And when men focus almost
solely on large animals,
they sometimes run the risk
of coming home empty-handed,
especially in more arid
environments such as this one
where animals are patchy and
very infrequently encountered.
So per hour spent hunting,
a kangaroo hunter does tend
to average a higher return
than a monitor lizard hunter
taking home over a kilo of meat,
while a sand monitor hunter
gets only a third of that.
But the meat from larger animals,
kangaroo, bustard, and that sort of thing
comes in only very infrequently,
about once and in every five hunts.
And although the average is higher,
there are often many days
when nothing is acquired by any hunter.
So, in comparison, women's hunting
is much more reliable than men's.
They don't have as many big bonanzas,
but they also don't have as many days
with less than they might need.
Men only end up out-producing
women on 25% of days.
And on 37% of days no men are successful
at hunting any type of game.
Fully a third of these meat
droughts are between about three
and six days in duration.
And for women, in comparison,
failure is less than 5%
and they don't have any meat droughts.
So, even though larger animals
have a higher mean return,
in reality, this obscures the fact
that men's production comes in the form
of these periodic huge bonanzas
and long meat droughts rather
than a steady daily stream.
The meat from larger animals
is also distributed widely.
The hunter keeps only
about 10% for himself
and his own family.
After sharing, the returns
to a hunter's family
in terms of the grams of meat
per hour hunting is the same,
regardless of what kind of
animal has been acquired.
Now, if women's hunting is more reliable
and provides similar payoffs
to family consumption
when successful as does men's hunting,
then it might suggest maybe
that the goals of foraging for
men and women are different,
that men might be hunting
to show off their skill
and attract alliances
and favorable attention,
while women are foraging simply
to feed themselves and their families.
So women hunt more
reliable smaller animals
and they trade off this
reliability with larger harvests
because reliability is a better way
to reduce the risks of going hungry.
So it might suggest something
like men hunt to share
and women hunt to eat.
Men use the hunting and
sharing of highly-valued meat
to engage themselves in
these political arenas
of social competition and social support.
And kangaroo hunting by men
is an overtly political game
where young men hunt
for public consumption.
They donate their labor to gain the trust
that's required to gain access
to deeper levels of ritual secrets
which are very important for men.
They work to provide meat for all,
especially in-laws and potential in-laws
without any material reward
in order to gain the trust of older men
who guard the way that
secret ritual knowledge
is transferred and gained.
So a man who demonstrates willingness
to work for the public good
is trusted with more ritual secrets
and he can rise in the ritual hierarchy.
A man who demonstrates willingness
to work for his in-laws
was traditionally trusted
with the opportunity to
marry their daughter.
Hunting for men is as
much about assuring trust
and cooperation in the
distribution of meat,
as it is about showing off
skill and acquiring meat.
When men talk about the
benefits of hunting,
they emphasize that they hunt to share,
they don't hunt eat or
favor their own children
and families over others.
If men hunt to share,
do women then hunt only
to feed their families?
When you hunt with Martu women
what puzzles you the
most is not the hunting,
it's actually the sharing.
So more than 70% of the
time women's harvests
of small animals are shared
well beyond their own families.
And on an astounding 23% of lizard hunts,
a successful hunter will
take nothing for herself.
She gives it all away either
to her own family members
or other people sitting
around the cooking fire.
When women share, they often
exchange identical lizards
and the hunter will always
give away the largest prey
to someone else.
Lizards are shared to others
who have already eaten.
In this video, the hunter returned late
and she's the last to
cook and share her harvest
and she gives away
nearly the entire harvest
to other women and men in the group.
She keeps only the bottom
half of one for herself.
One of the women that
cooperated with her hunting,
she receives three lizards
in the initial division.
She passes two to those sitting behind her
and one to the woman on her left.
And the hunter passes one to her husband.
Things are transferring back and forth.
And ultimately, out of a
harvest of six large lizards,
each hunter received less than 8%.
And all of the non-hunters got portions
that were actually bigger than each
of the hunter's portion.
And the goal in this
distribution was to make sure
everyone present around the
fire had an equal-sized portion
and nobody went hungry.
Not only do women share
extensively with each other,
they share in ways that don't
make sense economically.
So women often exhibit a
producer's disadvantage in sharing.
So when you have a
producer's disadvantage,
the size of the portion the
hunter, the producer keeps,
is smaller than the average size
of portions given away to those
that didn't participate in the hunt.
And the usual cross-cultural
pattern is for producers
to take an advantage to
compensate themselves
for paying the cost of going out
and acquiring the food item, right?
They usually keep a portion
that's bigger than any
of the portions that are
given out to non-hunters.
But when Martu women hunt small animals
like monitor lizards,
they often keep a smaller
individual portion
than the average portion size given
to a non-hunter or family member.
And we don't see this pattern for men.
When men share small animals,
they'll take the producer's advantage
and they'll keep a larger
portion for themselves.
Women compared to men also
give away more portions.
Given an average-sized harvest,
women will give out more than
twice as many portions as men.
They usually give out around six compared
to men who give out two.
Because they give out
more portions than men,
their average portion size
is a little bit smaller,
but they prevent the portion size
of becoming too small
by stinting themselves
in favor of feeding others.
Now, the cost that the
hunter pays doesn't seem
to be balanced by shares coming in.
So a successful hunter
gets significantly less
from others than an unsuccessful hunter
or someone who didn't hunt at all.
So that the hunter who acquired the most
often takes home the
smallest share of meat
after all sharing has been accounted for.
So women are way too
generous with small prey
than we might expect if we're thinking
about sort of the simple
economics of sharing.
It's also the case that in the sharing,
women are not just sending
those larger shares
to family members, stinting
their own consumption in favor
of their children or their close kin.
Women also share widely beyond
their own kinship network
and they also share mainly to other women.
So this is a network of
sharing relationships
between people who made
dinner camps with each other.
The circular nodes, the circles are women.
The squares are men.
And the color corresponds
to the kinship clusters
in the bottom diagram.
Those are the four, five
major kinship clusters
in the community.
The ties between each
of the nodes are those
who had shares of meat
passing between them.
Sharing cross cuts kinship ties
and it brings together women
from all kinship clusters
in the community.
So our hypothesis that women are hunting
to provision their families
seems poorly supported.
Why hunt at all if it's
only going to share,
if you're only going to share most of it
to unrelated dinner camp members.
Martu themselves suggest
that one of the main reasons
that women hunt is to acquire meat
to share with other women.
When Martu women talk about hunting,
they describe their underlying motivation
as hunting to share.
This is especially the case for women
who are known as murtilya, good hunters.
Anyone can gain the
status of a good hunter,
but to be a murtilya, you
don't simply produce more,
you also share more of that
production with others.
So as one hunter put it, "When
a murtilya goes out hunting,
"she has a good feeling that
she's going to get so much
"and be able to feed others.
"Good hunters always think
that when they go out
"and it helps them to hunt better.
"When a really good hunter goes out,
"she gives so much away
"and takes home only a
small piece for herself,
"but she will always walk
away feeling pukurrpa."
Pukurrpa is what women see
is the reward for murtilyas.
So pukurrpa means generally
warmth and happiness.
But it's a happiness that's the product
of generosity that binds people together.
Without generosity, you
feel you're not in a family,
you're just for yourself
not for everybody,
you don't share things.
According to Martu, good hunters share
in order to demonstrate their commitment
to building family and
contributing to the public good.
And this is the kind of sharing
that we would experience
around the dinner table.
It's the sharing that
cements social relationships,
that feeds and nourishes, but
treats everyone like family.
Theoretically, we know that the generation
of warmth and trust or
demonstrating generosity tends
to have substantial effects
on the likelihood of cooperation.
And there's been quite a bit
of experimental work suggesting
that people tend to cooperate with
and trust more of those
who demonstrate generosity.
And this suggests that one
reason women share so widely
may have something to do
with their cooperative social networks.
Martu women are more than twice as likely
as men to hunt cooperatively.
And for some hunting activities
more than 40 times
likely to be cooperative.
Women also cooperate in childcare, cooking
and other daily activities in ways
that cross cut their
residential group memberships.
Older and younger women,
even those from different hearth groups,
will team up to cooperate in childcare
and different forms of foraging
and subsistence activities,
dividing their labor
so that some will hunt
while others collect.
One of the most frequent
forms of cooperation today
is in small animal hunting.
So this is a small animal
cooperative hunting network.
Hunting partners help each
other out in tracking, digging
and searching for prey.
They usually pool their catch.
Again the same sort of colors
are indicating the kin groups.
And it turns out that
women who are more generous
on average, but not those
who are the necessarily the best hunters
are more central in this
cooperation network,
meaning they have more partners
and they have more partners
who are also more generous.
So this supports the hypothesis
that one of the main
reasons that women share
is to foster more
cooperative relationships
with other women.
So this story of women's
hunting in desert Australia
gives us a much different picture
of the goals of hunting and
its associations with gender
than we've generally gotten
from another hunter-gatherers.
It breaks a lot of our assumptions
about who hunts and why.
Foraging women can be
efficient hunters and trackers,
and small animal hunting
can be just as productive
and more reliable than
large animal hunting.
Women can even specialize on small animals
if it's reliable enough.
Women can support a number of others
from their hunting
efforts, not just children,
and can engage with others as cooperative,
political and social agents
outside of the spousal union.
Women could share meat outside
of their immediate families
and draw on those ties
created through meat sharing
to engage in other cooperative endeavors.
Women can form divisions
of labor with other women
and in so doing,
collaboratively (babbles),
collaboratively both care
and provision dependence
with meat independently of men.
So a model of the origins of human hunting
and sociality based on women's acquisition
and sharing of small animals, I think,
is at least as plausible, if not more so,
than models based on
men's hunting of big game
and women's dependence on
men's hunting production.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- I do study chimpanzees in a savanna
and I'd like to tell you a
little bit more about that site
because it does have a
lot of importance as far
as the chimpanzees' hunting behavior goes.
And this map I will show you,
most of the long-term
chimpanzee study sites
operating today, not all of them,
but these sites most of
them here have been ongoing
for at least 10 years and in some cases,
and the case of Gombe and
Mahale, more than 50 years.
And so, most of you are probably
familiar with Jane Goodall
and at least the person,
but Gombe is the site
that she helped to establish
that Ian talked about.
I'm across the continent
and I'm over in West Africa,
this is my site, the Fongoli study site.
And I chose this site
because it is in a savanna
and we think that our lineage,
evolutionarily speaking
evolved in this type of habitat
and so I'll show you some
images from the site.
My underlying questions have to do
with how these chimpanzees differ
from chimpanzees living in forests,
like the chimps we've heard about before
and in Goualougo and in Gombe.
And I will cite Jim Moore here,
he's written a lot about using chimpanzees
as what we call a referential model
and that is comparing them
to chimpanzees living in a forested site.
And the assumption is that the
environment will have effects
on their behavior.
And I did think this going in,
I had ideas about what
the differences might be
and the chimps kind of went their own way
and showed me a lot more
differences, including hunting,
and so I'll talk to you about that today.
So though I'm going to talk
about three main questions
and I focus on the types of hunting
or aspects of the Fongoli
chimpanzees' hunting
that you don't necessarily
see at other sites
or that are very rare.
And so one of the things
that we see here commonly
is that chimpanzees hunt with tools
and that's something that we
use to define our own species.
It has been seen literally
a handful of times
at another site in Tanzania,
but at Fongoli chimpanzees
do this quite frequently
so we've seen hundreds of cases now
and I'll talk to you more about that.
So one of the questions that I'll touch on
is why hunt with tools in
this particular habitat?
Something else that is not really common
at other chimpanzee sites is that in fact
in regarding this
particular type of hunting,
females are more frequently
going to be those hunting
with tools compared to males,
and as we heard that's just not the case
in most other chimpanzee study sites,
so I'll talk more about that.
And then to follow up with David's talk,
I will talk about meat sharing
or I use the word sharing
and I'll talk about how I define that,
but I'll specifically talk
about how females dole out meat.
And then finally I'll
come back to this idea
about using chimpanzees as a model
and what perhaps the Fongoli chimpanzees
that I study can help us
say or think about in terms
of the evolution of early
hominin or bipedal ape hunting.
So these are some images
from my study site,
the Fongoli study site
is one of the hottest,
driest and most vegetatively
open sites that you see today
where chimpanzees have
actually been habituated
to human presence.
So this took us quite a long
time, it took us four years.
I started in 2001 and we
habituated males to our presence
by 2005, but I wasn't able to identify
all the chimpanzees in
the group until 2006.
That's when we identified all the females,
this is a view of my
pretty fancy camp there.
And hopefully that gives you
some idea of the vegetation.
So it's a woodland savanna,
the dominant understory
is grass the savanna,
but you do have a large proportion
of the habitat as woodlands.
Over half of the habitat is woodland
and only a very small portion is forest,
about 3% of the habitat is forest
and this is where you
find your water sources.
This is really the chimpanzees'
most limiting resource
at Fongoli is water.
Temperatures are incredibly hot,
really hot for me, even hot for chimps.
So right now we're, well,
yeah, the month of March
in Senegal is almost approaching
the peak of the dry season
so temperatures are
regularly over 100 degrees.
They may get up to 115 or so.
During the rainy season or
at least at the beginning
of the rainy season, you find some relief
because the trees will
put out leaves again.
They lose all their trees
during the dry season.
But yet you have this lag,
you have hot temperatures
and then you have this high
humidity which is really fun.
And so, literally...
(audience laughing)
The heat index in June is around 120-125,
and that's when I take students out.
(audience laughing)
So a little bit about
the Fongoli study group.
Within this particular habitat
they have a very large
home range, 110 kilometers,
which is one of the largest,
if not the largest, so far described.
The community size is relatively small,
it's not the smallest
chimpanzee community studied,
but it's on the small
size, around 35 chimps.
And importantly we have
a sex ratio that is sort
of the opposite of what
you see at other sites.
So we have more males than females,
that's usually not the case.
And the data that I'm
gonna talk about today stem
from 2005 through 2017.
One other thing I'll say about adult males
versus adult females
is, because of the fact
that when I first got to Fongoli I heard
that even though chimpanzees
are not eaten at the site
and this is not within a national park,
this is outside of a national park
so you do have villages
in the area, anthropogenic
or human disturbance accounts
for about 5% of the habitat.
You do have chimpanzees
living alongside people,
they're not habituated to them,
they're habituated to us, so we're okay
but other people are not.
But in rare cases you do have people
that will try to hunt a chimpanzee
in order to get a female's
infant for the pet trade
and we had that happen
one time in 17 years.
And because of that,
I focus on adult males
as my focal subjects.
The Fongoli community is often
together as one large group,
so I can collect data on females,
but they are more timid
when they're by themselves
and I don't try to follow them
when they're by themselves.
So I think I know a lot about
what is going on with males
and I know some about what
is going on with females
but perhaps not as much.
So this pie chart gives you an idea
of the prey species consumed
by Fongoli chimpanzees both
by males and by females.
And as Ian pointed out,
there are no colobus monkeys
in this particular habitat.
So it is a savanna woodland habitat,
colobus monkeys don't occur here.
Forest guenons like red-tailed monkeys
or other colobus monkeys, blue
monkeys do not occur here.
Instead you have savanna
species like baboons,
patas monkeys, vervets.
You have mongooses,
bushbucks, things like this.
And then on the very lower right,
you see that adorable little bush baby
and Ian introduced the galago as well.
The galago is actually
the main prey species
of Fongoli chimpanzees,
both males and females,
and this is the animal
that they hunt with tools
and I'll actually hopefully
show you some video of that
and talk more about that.
So the prey profile, if
you wanna call it that,
really reflects the
savanna type of habitat
and it does also support
as Ian pointed out
or talked about what is
called a risk-averse strategy.
So I'm just going to show you some video
and try to narrate it here.
So this is tool-assisted hunting.
What this image is gonna show you
is an adult female
that's, if you can't tell,
that's Farafa, she's an older female.
We estimate her age to be around 40.
She's one of the top female
hunters in the group.
So she's trying to get at these
adorable little bush babies
that try to sleep in
cavities during the day
until this rude chimpanzee
comes with the tool.
That's an adult male, that's Jumpkin,
and he goes about it a
little bit differently.
(audience laughing)
And so, even though females
hunt with tools more
than expected, I'll talk a
little bit more about that next,
males do exhibit this type
of hunting behavior as well.
(audience laughing)
I have to say he's
usually better than that.
(audience laughing)
They just caught him on a bad day.
Well, we'll let Jumpkin try one more time.
(audience laughing)
If you didn't guess he wasn't successful
in this particular bout.
So we're looking at a lot of
different aspects of this.
Well...
(audience laughing)
I almost feel bad showing that.
We're looking at a lot
of different aspects
of this particular behavior
and so this is a juvenile female, Vivian,
that was her mother that was hunting.
And the juveniles start this behavior
when they're about two years of age,
when they're still infants and nursing,
but they don't learn really
the proper, you know,
tool length and that sort of thing
until they get to be about four.
So she gets a little frustrated too.
(audience laughing)
All right, enough fun, I guess.
(clears throat)
So, in terms of our results so far, um...
I apologize because in your
abstract I put over 500,
I was sure that we would
hit the 500 mark this year.
499, I just can't believe it.
(audience laughs)
But we have 499 hunting records,
those aren't all successes
and that's including adults and immatures.
We've only seen adolescent
and adult individuals
successful in this type
of hunting behavior.
Like I said, infants begin to exhibit it
and they do really good
as far as making the tool
but they don't make a proper tool
until they get to be a juvenile.
So we see about 32 hunts
per year on average
when you take into account
that there are some days
that we can't be there,
the river's too high
or someone's sick.
We think that they probably
hunt at least 50 times a year.
And, again, our most
recent analysis suggest
that females do hunt
significantly more than expected
with tools, even though males also hunt.
And we did analysis taking into account
not only their membership
in the community as a whole
but also their membership
and so-called hunting parties
or parties that the chimpanzees
are in on those days.
So, I want to talk a little bit more
about just the hunters themselves,
and this is a lot of color there,
but I wanted to show you the
top 10 hunters at Fongoli
and also the different types of foods
or prey that they hunt.
And so, you have two
females that are actually
among the top 10 hunters at Fongoli.
Interestingly, I think is
that both of those females,
females are very high-ranking.
So Tumbo there is currently
our alpha female based
on these very stylized pant grunt records,
sorry, vocalizations, and we keep records
of these vocalizations where
a subordinate individual
will pant, grunt to a dominant individual.
And Tumbo actually overtook
that alpha position
from Farafa there about two years ago.
And so, females actually do
hunt some in this community
or at least enough to be considered
among the top 10 Fongoli hunters.
And also I'd like to point out
that we have a tie right now
for the very top hunter,
and one is the alpha male,
that's David.
He is tied for the top
hunting position with Siberut
and some of you will be
happy to know that Siberut
who is pictured there is
not only the oldest hunter
in the group, he's oldest male,
but he's also the lowest
ranking male as well.
And then if you look at female
hunting behavior in general,
females, almost all females hunt
and almost all males hunt as well,
so they hunt about what you would expect
or at least their participation
in hunting overall
is what you would expect based
on their their membership
in the Fongoli community.
I wanted to look, talk a little
bit about Fongoli hunting
and the context of female
hunting across study sites.
So, Ian talked about that some
and I've used data from
his work and others
to look at Fongoli female
hunting and, in fact,
there are females
elsewhere that also engage
in quite a bit of hunting.
In fact, females at
Mahale hunt a little more
than females at Fongoli if you look
at Fongoli female
hunting behavior overall.
And then when you look at tool use,
you see that Fongoli
females do hunt quite a bit,
almost half of the tool-assisted hunting
at Fongoli is by females.
And, again, remember that we
have fewer females at Fongoli,
we don't follow females
systematically like we do males.
And so one question as to why females hunt
is basically as David started out with,
you know, it's probably no surprise
that the chimps gained a lot
of nutrition from hunting,
but I think perhaps a
more interesting question
is why females don't
hunt more at other sites.
And Ian talked about some
of these issues as well
that I'll pursue right now.
And so, if you looked
at for example theft,
there's not a lot of theft at Fongoli,
so when I use the word share
I'm referring to, basically,
the last three categories I
think that David talked about.
So active food transfer
but not theft, right,
and passive food transfer, et cetera.
So I consider theft to
be a different category
and at Fongoli you have very little theft.
The only thought we've seen involves
two different alpha males,
so very little theft.
Whereas at other sites you
do have quite a bit of theft
and so I believe, as Ian said,
females don't have incentive
to hunt at some sites.
At Fongoli there definitely is incentive
and not only females, but this
is a little video of, again,
that lower-ranking male.
So out of 13 males he's number 13.
He's the oldest male, that's Siberut.
So he's walking by a number of adult males
with this bushbuck fawn that he's captured
and no one makes any
attempt to take it from him.
He had actually been eating
on that fawn for over an hour
and he had a number of
individuals sitting around
basically begging, he
didn't share with them.
And as he moves off you'll see
that there's another older
male that will follow him
and this is his ally, Bandit.
Where's Bandit?
There he is.
Calmly following his buddy Siberut out.
And so, he did end up sharing with Bandit.
So not only do you see
some sort of concept...
Well, I hate to say concept of ownership
but you see tolerance.
So tolerance of possession of prey, uh...
By dominant males of these
low ranking individuals,
females and also lower ranking males.
So I think that at
Fongoli you actually have
the incentive to hunt.
It's one of the reasons that
you see so much hunting,
at least tool-assisted hunting in females.
I wanna show it a slightly different way.
So, these are the same top 10 hunters,
but rather than being
expressed in the number of prey
that they brought in, this
is the number of kilograms
or estimated kilograms of meat, right?
And so, you see that David has jumped up
to number one position there.
It depends on what you hunt
and almost everybody hunts
bush babies except K.L.,
we've never seen him capture a bush baby.
But what's interesting is you see
that the third top hunter there,
at least in terms of prey captures, Lupin,
has fallen quite low because he does seem
to specialize on bush babies.
So the females really didn't
change positions at all,
they're still in the top 10,
but you do see a lot of variation.
So that's something that
we're looking at now,
and so, I wanted to talk just a little bit
about what females can provide
in terms of transfer or sharing.
And we...
So far this is still
preliminary to some degree.
We've looked at sharing or
food transfer by females,
and again I'm considering
David's categories
of active transfer, passive transfer
and scrounging but tolerated scrounging,
and I'm not considering
a theft in this category.
Females actually shared
with other individuals
more often they did with their offspring.
So that's something that
we're exploring right now.
And, basically, I would
argue that females,
as Rebecca has pointed out,
should be considered as well.
And, finally, I'll just
move on to my last slide
and leave you with a couple of thoughts.
First of all, I think
Travis Pickering said it
probably better than I can.
So, he actually thinks that if you...
Think about the tool-assisted
hunting at Fongoli,
it perhaps can tell us more about some
of the early hominin hunting
that went on compared
to the emotionally-charged
hunting of chimpanzees,
as he puts it.
And I'll just end up by saying,
echoing what Rebecca has said
as well about female humans,
is that just now, and I
think Richard mentioned this
as well, we're beginning
to understand more
about female chimpanzee hunting,
and that they also play
a part in this scenario.
So, thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(uptempo music)